bienvenue sur la croisette cannes c'est
la terre des cinéphiles c'est aussi une
belle vitrine médiatique
ludovic de gaillande compte bien en
profiter pour se faire connaître ce
natif de nouvelle calédonie a eu un
parcours plutôt atypique et après un
master de sciences politiques et s'est
très vite tourné vers le cinéma
c'est comme ça que ludovic s'est
retrouvé au troisième c'est l'institut
international de l'image et du son de
trappes à cannes au short film corner
ludovic est venu présenter son nouveau
corps métrage var dogger film librement
inspiré d'une légende nordique au maire
prend moins d'une semaine
ça ne fait pas peur ce malade qui se
balade dans les rues est-ce que c'est
toi qui as utilisé mon appareil photo
c'est un film de genre un thriller
fantastique il ya des meurtres à paris
et on a un photographe qui est allemand
qui va commencer à être persécutés à se
sentir persécuté par une présence à mi
sérieuse comme sa présence qui va se
manifester à travers son appareil photo
et qui nourrit qui n'arriva pas à saisir
à prendre en photo et du suspense autour
de ça on apprend plus sur le personnage
à travers cette musique c'est ma
première fois à cannes
c'est plus du bonus en fait
ce que j'attends c'est de prendre déjà
observé voir comment
comment les gens interagissent entre eux
dans ce milieu a rencontré des gens qui
peuvent être ensuite des tremplins des
aspirations des soutiens
et et puis éventuellement en bonus peut
être un acheteur pour pour le film a
diffusé en tout cas
pour éventuellement espace soit aidé
soit en vod quelque part le festival de
cannes c'est aussi l'occasion pour les
professionnels du réalisateur à
l'exploitant de se pencher sur la santé
du cinéma qu'elle pineau et le directeur
du grenier à sel de trappes le site
accueille quelques 25000 spectateurs
chaque année à cannes gaël est à la
recherche d'idées pour développer
l'activité de la salle et attirer le
grand public
dans notre métier on n'a pas vraiment de
formation et c'est pas évident
mais à toujours se renouveler de
développer une nouvelle chose de donc là
on vient ici on prend des idées des uns
des autres on se rend compte en mange
ensemble on sait une chose assez
informelle quand on fait la queue pour
attendre un film on en profite aussi
beaucoup pour pour discuter écouter ce
qu'ont ce que font les uns les autres et
qu'il ya sur ces pour voir les films
parce que la plupart des filles qui sont
festival de cannes on les retrouve dans
deux salles art et essai à l'intérêt
c'est pas 2 c'est pas de rester un
cinéma de mamie qui qui attend les films
toutes les semaines et qui fait rien de
particulier on est toujours
il a toujours envie de nouvelles choses
je parlais de développement de nouvelles
idées de faire des choses à côté du un
côté du cinéma de faire des partenariats
de voir
vous avez fait un débat avec tel film
vous avez fait comment vous aviez ya un
monsieur qui était venu avec une guitare
à d'accord c'est décidé qu'on peut avoir
comme ça et qu'on ait des changements
partager et qui permet de ne pas avoir
toujours toujours toujours la même chose
dans l'eau salée pas avoir uniquement un
film
manière basique et on se quitte avec
notre star du jour son nom ne vous dit
peut-être rien et pourtant sylvain
chomet est un dessinateur scénariste de
bande dessinée de films d'animation il
est né à maisons laffitte
il a réalisé le film d'animation les
triplettes de belleville et notamment le
clip carmen de stromae à cannes il signe
un court métrage pour les talents adami
le titre c'est merci monsieur et madame
j'avais eu les triplettes de belleville
donc
oui après après j'ai regardé le parcours
bien sûr comme on travaille avec
quelqu'un c'est bien de savoir un peu de
connaître un peu l'univers il est très
bienveillant et en même temps il est
assez minutieux
c'est à dire que s'il ya quelque chose
qui ne va pas il va le dire avec toute
la douceur du monde
mais tant que ça n'ira pas aux piles
lâchera pas ce qui fait que
on sait qui nous amène à un endroit à
l'endroit où on sera le mieux
et simone et si on a du mal à y parvenir
c'est pas grave il prendra le temps
qu'il faut hop pour être pour qu'on soit
au bon endroit et ça c'est agréable sur
certains tournages quelquefois n'y a pas
le temps donc même si nous on sait qu'on
n'a pas été vraiment au bon endroit
y a pas le temps donc on continue et ça
c'est un peu frustrant
là vraiment tout était à sa place il
avait du temps pour nous il a été très
bienveillant l'équipe ça s'est très très
bien passé à les moteurs 1 sur 1 1re 478
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
et n'oubliez pas comme le dit claude
lelouch le cinéma est fait pour tous
ceux dont la curiosité est le plus grand
défaut